Che cosa ci riveleranno
le neuroscienze applicate
sul futuro del pensiero umano?
Quando ho cominciato a riflettere
su che cosa avrei voluto
raccontare su questo tema,
l'immagine esatta che si è
visualizzata nel mio cervello
è quella che vedete alle mie spalle,
ovvero il buio totale.
Che è più o meno quello che si prova
dieci secondi prima
di uscire su questo palco.
Poi mi si è aperto uno spiraglio,
perché chi come me
è cresciuto negli anni Settanta
ha sempre associato il futuro dell'umanità
e dell'Intelligenza Artificiale
ai robot umanoidi,
a questi esseri di latta,
neanche tanto belli,
che avrebbero rappresentato, magicamente,
l'esito del pensiero umano
in qualcosa di superiore.
Arrivato lì, mi sono di nuovo perso.
Non riuscivo a trovare lo spiraglio
per capire che cosa c'entrasse
questa cosa dei robot
con il mio lavoro attuale.
Allora ho consultato
il mio filosofo di riferimento,
che si chiama Gennady Pietro Ubiali,
ha otto anni,
e per mia fortuna vive con me,
perché è mio figlio.
È un filosofo italo-russo
che ancora non è così famoso.
A un certo punto,
mentre io mi dibatto
in questo groviglio di pensieri,
lui viene da me,
mi guarda con una certa pietà
e io gli dico:
"Senti Gennady, mi devi aiutare:
ma noi, nel futuro dell'umanità,
che cos'è che insegneremo ai robot?".
E lui, senza la minima esitazione,
mi dice "Le buone maniere".
Poi prende e se ne va,
perché ovviamente un bambino di otto anni
ha uno span di attenzione di una zanzara,
e quindi mi abbandona
Io, di nuovo, rimango
solo con me stesso,
ma mi si è accesa un'altra luce.
Sì, perché se quello
che insegneremo ai robot,
se la parte essenziale del pensiero umano
che vogliamo trasferire ai robot
fosse veramente come dice
il mio filosofo di riferimento,
l'empatia, le buone maniere
presuppongono che voi
sappiate leggere in anticipo
i sentimenti del vostro interlocutore.
Ci ho visto un collegamento.
Io ho un grande privilegio:
sono co-founder
e amministratore di un'azienda
che tutti i giorni si occupa
di neuroscienze applicate.
Immaginate un'azienda
che passa il suo tempo
in giro per il mondo
a raccogliere dati neurologici
su esseri umani che fanno
esperienze nella vita reale:
guidano un'auto, prendono un aereo,
vanno in un bosco, mangiano un piatto.
E io ho una poltrona
di prima fila, strepitosa.
L'inghippo nasce dal fatto
che io sono laureato in filosofia,
quindi sono co-founder
di un'azienda che fa neuroscienza
e non capisco niente di neuroscienza.
Non è esattamente così:
però sono l'unico filosofo nella stanza.
È un vantaggio o uno svantaggio?
Quando mio figlio mi dice
che secondo lui il futuro
dell'intelligenza artificiale,
e del pensiero umano,
è il trasferimento della capacità empatica
e della capacità umana
di provare emozione,
improvvisamente mi rendo conto
che la poltrona su cui io sono seduto
è una poltrona privilegiata,
perché ho il posto in prima fila
su quello che, durante
la sua gloriosa carriera,
Alan Turing a un certo punto postula,
quando dice:
"Dalla materia nasce la coscienza".
Pensate, io sto seduto
tutti i giorni in prima fila
e guardo le neuroscienze
applicate che misurano -
potrei allungare la mano
e mettere il dito,
non me lo fanno fare
perché non hanno stima di me in azienda;
però potrei allungare la mano,
e toccare con un dito,
quel luogo misterioso del nostro cervello
in cui dalla materia nasce,
attraverso un'attività chimica, elettrica,
quello che noi chiamiamo
la coscienza, il pensiero.
Finalmente cominciavo a intravedere
il senso profondo del mio guru Gennady,
perché mi sono reso conto che, forse,
quello che le neuroscienze applicate,
che noi portiamo in giro
per tutto il pianeta oggi,
potevano insegnarci sul futuro
del pensiero degli uomini
era qualcosa di veramente nuovo
da raccontarvi.
Allora, entusiasta di questa trovata,
ho condiviso questo pensiero
con i neuroscienziati del nostro team.
Destando grande sconforto,
perché quando mi sono rivolto
ai neuroscienziati del nostro team,
ho detto:
"Bene, ma allora che cosa stiamo capendo
di questo ammasso complesso
che secondo gli ultimi articoli
della letteratura neuroscientifica
è in grado di computare
come un computer quantico
a sei, otto dimensioni?
Ragazzi, devo andare su un palco
a raccontare al mondo, attraverso TEDx,
che cosa tiriamo fuori da lì
sull'essenza del pensiero umano.
E questi mi hanno detto:
"Sostanzialmente nulla adesso, Mario".
Ah.
Allora, per dimostrare
che i soldi dei miei genitori
non erano andati completamente sprecati,
sono tornato a quella poltrona
di cui vi parlavo.
Mi sono cioè domandato
se in realtà il problema di fondo
non fosse che quando voi misurate
la complessa attività neuroelettrica
di quell’ammasso assolutamente intricato
di tessuti, di cellule -
chiamateli come volete -
quando voi siete lì,
e state misurando quello,
forse spiegare come quello funziona,
e come da quella materia, diceva Turing,
"si origina il vostro pensiero",
richiede qualcosa di diverso.
Allora, facendo ricorso
ai soldi ben spesi dai miei genitori,
mi sono rivolto a questo signore,
che è l'altro mio filosofo di riferimento:
un pochino più vecchio -
questo potrei averlo come nonno,
quell'altro è mio figlio.
Questo signore si chiama Martin Heidegger.
Per chi ha crisi di insonnia,
è una cura ideale.
Seriamente parlando,
è un grande filosofo del Novecento,
un uomo molto controverso.
Ma l'aiuto che gli chiediamo oggi
per figurarci come
le neuroscienze applicate
possono insegnarci qualcosa sulla natura
del futuro del nostro pensiero,
ci viene da una sua rarissima,
e divertentissima intervista del 1954,
che trovate su YouTube se vi interessa.
Va in televisione, alla fine
di una carriera lunghissima, brillante:
ha scritto libri
che richiedono altri libri
per essere interpretati,
e dice una cosa che passa ovviamente
sotto un silenzio assordante.
Dice: "Ci sono due tipi di pensiero umano.
Un pensiero è il pensiero
cosiddetto degli enti".
I filosofi hanno questa
difficoltà a parlar chiaro.
"Il pensiero degli enti",
ci dice Heidegger,
"sarebbe il pensiero
che serve a capire le cose",
La meccanica delle cose:
lui lo associa al pensiero
scientifico-tecnologico.
Lui dice che sì, questa roba qui
la sanno fare tutti gli esseri umani,
sono capaci tutti.
Non dimenticatevi che qui stiamo parlando,
per esempio, di Intelligenza Artificiale.
Forse una lampadina già si sta accendendo.
Il pensiero degli enti,
le regole con cui operare sulle cose,
è un pensiero che è facile
da insegnare a una macchina.
Poi, però, siccome Heidegger
è un po' sadico,
e questo chi ha studiato
filosofia lo sa bene,
basta fare un esame
di Ermeneutica Filosofica,
aggiunge con grande nonchalance
che c'è un secondo tipo di pensiero.
Lui dice: "Guardate,
questo è un pensiero
ben più difficile da praticare.
Lo praticano in pochissimi,
tra tutti gli esseri umani".
Pensate un po' questo,
che dice questa roba
in televisione, e dice:
"Quest'altro pensiero
è il pensiero delle essenze.
Il pensiero delle essenze,
il pensiero che serve
a comprendere il senso delle cose".
Già così non è proprio
una cosa palatabile.
Giusto per rendere le cose
un po' più complicate -
però abbiate pazienza con me,
poi lo mettiamo lì e lo riprendiamo
tra qualche minuto -
il buon Heidegger dice:
"Ecco, questo tipo di pensiero
che vi sto raccontando ora,
quello delle essenze,
è un pensiero poetico".
Lasciamola lì.
Venite a fare una passeggiata con me,
e ricordatevi che ci sono
due tipi di pensiero:
sposate la tesi Heideggeriana.
Immaginate di essere in montagna.
Immaginate, per vostra sfortuna,
di avere dormito in un bellissimo chalet,
vicino a un bosco,
con un team di neuroscienziati.
Vi svegliate alla mattina,
vi vestite per fare
una passeggiata comoda,
e noi vi mettiamo in testa
un elettroencefalogramma.
E decidiamo di registrare
tutta la vostra attività neurologica
mentre fate questa passeggiata.
Uscite, vi investe l'aria fresca.
Avete le dita ancora un po' intirizzite,
la rugiada del mattino
è sui prati intorno a voi.
C'è un sentiero che porta al bosco,
avanti cento metri,
e camminando sentite
il rumore della ghiaia,
sotto i vostri scarponcini.
Il sole sta sorgendo,
il cielo è già chiaro.
Voi vi avviate.
Quando entrate nel bosco,
come spesso accade in montagna,
c'è una leggera inversione termica:
nel bosco fa un po' più caldo,
i rumori si attutiscono lievemente;
ma i vostri sensi, improvvisamente,
sembrano misurare tutto meglio e di più.
Il rumore sotto i piedi è cambiato
perché ci sono delle foglie secche,
degli aghi.
Nell'aria ci sono aromi
sprigionati dalle resine, dalle piante.
Le dita si sono scaldate,
la vostra pelle
comincia a sudare leggermente:
abbassate la zip della giacca.
I primi uccelli del mattino
agitano dei rami.
Ne entite il suono, il fruscio:
li sentite cinguettare.
Più avanti sul sentiero,
un animale attraversa:
voi non avete capito qual è,
ma avete capito che non è pericoloso.
Se voi tornaste da questa passeggiata,
diciamo dopo un'oretta,
e la nostra equipe trasferisse
i dati che ha registrato,
per cominciare ad esaminarli,
che cosa vedremmo?
Vedremmo che tutto quello
che è accaduto nel vostro cervello
nell'arco di quell'esperienza -
e badate bene, questo era un esempio:
avrei potuto parlarvi
di qualunque esperienza
voi stiate facendo,
compresa quella che fate ora ascoltando -
avremmo visto una cosa molto interessante,
cioè che nel coacervo di dati
che noi abbiamo raccolto
sul vostro cervello
ce n'è una parte che si origina
dalla corteccia superiore
che si occupa dei processi cognitivi,
razionali, linguistici -
quello che voi, nella vostra
abitudine quotidiana,
tendete a pensare sia il vostro pensiero:
"Ah, fammi vedere cosa ho pensato!".
È un po' più complicato di così!
Perché il nostro team, quando io ho detto:
"Ragazzi, ma cosa stiamo scoprendo
sul pensiero profondo?",
mi hanno risposto "Nulla"?
In realtà, quello che loro vogliono dire
è che noi stiamo entrando
in una nuova era,
perché sotto la corteccia di quei pensieri
ci sta un'altra categoria di pensiero
che è una risposta profonda,
istintiva, non controllata
che il vostro cervello ha
a qualunque stimolo esterno.
Aspettate, è ancora meglio di così,
diventa ancora meglio di così:
il vostro cervello risponde
in maniera diversa
a seconda della natura degli stimoli
dell'ambiente che lo circonda,
secondo un principio
che più lo studiamo,
più sembra assomigliare
a quello che in fisica quantistica
viene chiamato entanglement.
Nel principio dell'entanglement,
la fisica quantistica dice
che se noi separiamo
due particelle subatomiche
provenienti dallo stesso atomo,
e ne mettiamo una a Ginevra
e una a Londra,
quando imprimeremo lo spin
a una delle due,
l'altra, istantaneamente,
subirà lo stesso spin.
Questa misteriosa interconnessione
adesso prendetela e trasferitela
sul rapporto tra il vostro cervello -
che incidentalmente, vorrei ricordarvi,
è fatto della stessa identica materia
di cui è fatto tutto l'universo
che ci circonda –
e quell'universo.
E allora, forse,
quello che noi stiamo scoprendo
con le neuroscienze applicate ogni giorno
non è conclusivo,
non è facile, non è lineare,
e richiede un salto di paradigma.
Per tutti gli ultimi 300 anni,
almeno, della nostra storia,
noi abbiamo salito una scala
per andare in alto.
Ci sembrava che il pensiero umano,
e il futuro del pensiero umano,
dovesse essere il futuro radioso
della logica più raffinata,
della cristallizzazione
dei migliori principi.
E salivamo questa scala.
E poi, a un certo punto
arriva uno come Wittgenstein
che dice "Ragazzi, abbiamo costruito
una scala favolosa.
Peccato che quando siamo stati in alto là,
la scala è cascata
e non riusciamo più a tornare giù".
Poi arriva un altro pazzo
che si chiama Gödel,
matematico amico di Einstein -
Einstein disse "Io vado a lavorare a piedi
da casa mia all'ufficio di Stanford
solo per poter camminare insieme a Gödel".
Quindi, se Einstein aveva
questa stima di Gödel,
potremmo dargli retta per due minuti.
Gödel a un certo punto postula la teoria,
il teorema dell'incompletezza.
Dice cioè che il sistema matematico
non è autosufficiente, non è conchiuso:
ha bisogno di un modello esterno
per stare in piedi.
Ma cosa c'entra questo
con le neuroscienze?
Cosa c'entra questo col nonno Heidegger?
C'entra tantissimo.
C'entra tantissimo,
perché quello che noi stiamo scoprendo
non è "su".
Non è il pensiero
che ci arrabattiamo tutti
a ragionare di trasferire nelle macchine.
Quello è il pensiero degli enti:
se il buon vecchio Heidegger
fosse ancora vivo
ci darebbe uno scappellotto e ci direbbe:
"Non hai capito niente!
Quello è il pensiero
degli enti, è roba facile!".
I robot possono già
assemblare un'automobile,
o far volare un aereo,
anche se l'idea non vi piace molto.
Ma che cos'è che ci rende umani?
Qual è la parte del pensiero
che dobbiamo riscoprire?
Non sarà per caso
che la parte del pensiero
che dobbiamo riscoprire sta "giù"?
Ma non è un "giù" qualitativo!
Non sarà per caso
che la parte del pensiero
che dobbiamo veramente
riscoprire come umana
è quella risposta profonda, istintiva,
emotiva, mnemonica, biologica -
tanto potete usare
tutti gli aggettivi che volete,
ma finché non fate il salto di paradigma,
finché non girate il tavolo,
non lo vedrete mai nella sua interezza.
Con la neuroscienza applicata
noi stiamo scoprendo solo un poco
questo intricato rapporto
di interconnessione
tra come il nostro cervello
risponde all'universo
e quello che quell'universo è.
E più andiamo avanti, e più lo scopriamo,
e più scopriamo che se noi leggiamo
l'essere umano in trasparenza,
siccome lui è fatto
dell'universo che c'è intorno,
quel pensiero, che rispecchia l'universo,
non richiede uno sforzo cognitivo.
Adesso avete capito perché Heidegger dice
che quell'altro tipo
di pensiero è poetico?
Perché quando dice poetico
lui vuole dire -
e lo dice in un altro suo libro -
"La verità di una cosa
succede nella mia testa,
come un raggio di sole
entra in una radura".
Il nostro lavoro di esseri umani
nella neuroscienza applicata
si sta rivelando profondamente filosofico
perché ci sta costringendo
a scoprire una interconnessione
per la quale non è sufficiente
la neuroscienza,
non è sufficiente il paradigma
della psicologia cognitiva,
non è sufficiente la fisica quantistica:
nessuna delle discipline,
da sola, sarà sufficiente
a capire qualcosa in più
e a gettare una luce.
Eppure, l'appello che io vorrei farvi,
sulla base del lavoro
che noi facciamo quotidianamente
è prima di tutto un appello umano.
Andando via da qui,
la mia preghiera
è la preghiera di ricordarvi
che prima di porci il problema
di cosa insegneremo ai robot,
di cosa trasferiremo sulle macchine,
di quale sarà il futuro
della meravigliosa, mirabolante
intelligenza artificiale,
non sarebbe affatto male
se ci focalizzassimo su quello che è
il nostro pensiero umano.
Se accettaste, uscendo da qui,
mettendovi a letto stasera
e spegnendo la luce -
non voglio rovinarvi la serata -
e chiudendo gli occhi,
che forse nel vostro cervello
può succedere un miracolo.
Ogni istante della vostra vita,
il vostro cervello risponde
in maniera sincrona
al mondo e all'universo che vi circondano.
E sapete qual è la notizia
drammaticamente importante?
Che se voi preserverete e salverete
questa idea di quello che siete
come esseri umani,
dovrete per forza salvare
l'universo che vi circonda.
Perché se quell'universo
sarà salvato, e sarà integro,
integra sarà la vostra parte più umana.
Nel salvare voi stessi,
voi salverete il mondo che vi circonda:
però dovrete fare una rivoluzione!
Una rivoluzione che, paradossalmente,
sta avvenendo dal mondo
delle neuroscienze.
Da una di quelle discipline
che viene considerata
più scientifica in assoluto.
Io penso che questo giorno
non sia così lontano.
Penso che questo giorno arriverà.
Penso che gli esseri umani
saranno in grado
di recuperare questa dimensione
del loro pensiero profondo.
E quando lo faranno,
un robot a cui nel frattempo
avranno insegnato le buone maniere
probabilmente ci offrirà un ottimo drink.
Grazie.
(Applausi)